okay hi guys uh happy to see all of you
here so today we are going to talk about
very interesting topic so i'll give you
some advices to
construct your next animal project
in better way so all this advice i've
learned either through my career
in my career either through my own
experience or
through other more experienced teammates
so first of all when we start uh
for our first project in uh or our next
project in machine learning we have to
have some clear expectations uh from
that project
first we can do a
project that is uh just one-time code
for a tiny problem so
its life expectancy is not very long so
it's like university exam or some
university small project or homework or
i don't know maybe a small demo tool
that we will never touch again but on
the other hand
we can have a
vision of that project to have a long
life cycle
that is that we want to build a lot of
good models uh get gather more data for
that model deployed somewhere
uh and the
this kind of problems can be for some
big businesses or even some startups or
businesses that that have uh to have a
long life cycle so during this talk we
will only focus
projects that are in this scale not some
uh student project skill so all advice
that i'm i will give you uh focused on
on this part
okay
uh if you want to be efficient in the
long run you gotta be slow so let me
explain this explain these dangerous
sentence that i dare to say
so uh if you uh start a new project and
ml uh your stakeholders come to you and
ask you to build uh deliver models as
fast as you can
but when you are being fast in in that
phase
you can have a lot of mistakes and uh
second when after in some time for
example after six months or after a year
when your stakeholders come to you and
ask for
a different kind of solution for
that specific problem or better model
you may need to restructure everything
you had previously to provide that
solution and in that phase you got you
will be very slow
so if you want to be
efficient and fast in long run in very
short term you gotta be slow to build
some infrastructure
and build some good code to provide
solutions in long term
so here's a meme about being being fast
at math so captain america is trying to
be
very fast
but but you know
sometimes sometimes you
not sometimes but you always should try
to be as correct as possible
even in
ml
so uh
let's
let's discuss some uh with concrete
examples of what bad code and bad design
or and full code can lead to concrete
examples first you and your co-worker uh
want to understand how your model works
in after some time for example you wrote
your your code you wrote your uh
functions and after
after some days later uh your co-workers
may not understand what what does it
does like in this
in this meme your co-worker uh ask you i
don't get your code what are these lines
for and you answer i have no idea but it
worked but it does not work without them
so
imagine imagine in uh six months when uh
you get some tasks you work on it you
solve everything it works properly
everything is fine your stakeholders are
okay with your model but
they ask for something new in six months
and you go back to your code and you
don't understand what you wrote there so
you gotta spend several uh hours or days
even if you wrote very bad code or this
part is very long you got to be
paid too much attention to your code to
understand what you wrote and change or
add some new functionalities
next because of the previous mentioned
problem uh you will spend more time on
debugging on that code in in that six
months period for example than actual
problem solving
so you will end up like all on the more
than this in this meme
the next problem is that onboarding new
new members can be painful for him or
her
when company grows a company wants more
hands to come and solve more business
problems but when your design is poor
and
poor uh new members
will spend a
lot of a lot of days a lot of hours from
their their work life to understand how
your design how your code worked
previously what you do did you do
in that code
to solve their new tasks so it will be
very very painful for there there and
you could just have some documentation
for your new team members to read and
understand
everything well
so
next i've talked about this briefly that
developing new features can become
harder and expensive so let's take a
look at concrete example how it is
so these graphs are from
anonymous engineering company from the
book clean architecture written by
robert c martin aka uncle bob so in the
upper graph you can see
this in x-axis there's a project release
tax from one to eight and in this y-axis
it's engineering uh staff number so we
see that engineering staff number is
really growing fast it's exponential
growth so anyone looking at only these
graphs can
say that company is really growing it
may solve a lot of engineering problems
but uh on the graph
below you can see
there is a project size defined in uh
thousands of lines and in on the same
period we see that project size is not
growing so much
so it's some asymptotic function it's
converging to some some number it it's
not growing so something is wrong here
engineering stuff is growing rapidly but
project is not growing so much
so if this doesn't resonate let's look
at another graph from the the same
company on the same period
so
uh from stakeholders perspective they
see that product productivity of
engineering uh stuff
is uh converging to 0.88 release so
it's it's not good but monthly payroll
skyrocket here
so we see 20 million dollars
paying to engineering team and they did
not produce
much so it's almost zero
so
robert c martin this company name is an
anonymous they they wanted to
stay anonymous but robert c martin uh
describes
described this problem as an uh
problem of poor cod and poor design and
poor architecture also
next as an email engineer
you need to do tons of
experiments and
when you have poor design and pool code
and your team members can
add new functionalities to your code
base experimenting with new models can
be become slower so in long run when
when you want to
experiment a new thing in your model you
may need to spend some days or hours to
change something in your code base
to write
to experiment with more models
and the
next uh next issue is that you can't
track how your model worked so you can
simply remember
your model all performance so uh it's
the issue of more uh not more poor code
but poor principles that you have uh
in your in your projects to follow so we
will talk about this issue later more
great examples but don't panic there's a
solution so there are some advice that
will
help you to build better project
first
so
who has this this kind of variables in
their code
okay
that's good so because uh this is the
first advice and simplest advice don't
uh don't have variables named one letter
variables like
x or war one or four that doesn't say
anything about your code
uh
your variables should be
self-explanatory
anyone reading your code should
understand what does function
does when reading just reading their
name that function name or your variable
name
also there are more examples like
putting instead of x like alpha but
writing alpha it's not one letter
variable but also it does not say much
you can just have a
self-explanatory variable and
in that case don't uh don't fear to have
long variable names
generally variables na variable names do
not take in memory in programming
languages in python they do but it's
very very very small you don't need to
care about that so you can have a very
long variable name but i'm not i'm not
urging you to
have sentence length variable name you
can just have short enough variable name
that are self-explanatory
so uh in the next slide there is a
meme about a bad variable name i won't
read it aloud but i will let you to read
this this part for yourself and when
you're done we'll go next
this this this comment is real common
from from the project
so it's definitely from a data science
project so
okay
has anyone already
okay
so
uh in the sake of this this example
don't don't have uh bad variable names
so please
uh next uh
i know that uh many of you got got
advice that uh
having comments in code is must
but you gotta remember that when you put
too much comments in your code that
means uh you speak more human language
than programming language
that means that your
code and that programming part is not
understandable
that you want to explain it in plain
english for someone
so in that case you you may have better
code and less less comment for that code
it's the ideal case when you have no
comments and your code is very
understandable that's the ideal case but
uh you may have
uh you may have some uh
code structure or some
some logic that very complicated it's
very difficult to explain by code itself
or some variable names it may become
very messy to to understand your
teammates want to understand anything so
you may put the comments on that part
but most of the comments on code become
something like that
so for example in code example uh you
can have
for example that variable named x is
equal to some array which calls logits
and you may put comment on
above that variable that this variable
uh stores logit but you may also also
can you can also put uh that variable
name just logics and everyone reading
your code will understand what your uh
variable does
so put comments only where necessary so
only on these complicated parts but for
humans you can write dog strings
especially in python it's very easy to
do so dog strings are for humans
computer does not read your dog strings
so you can have very long doctrines
explaining your code in detail even for
non-technical people
i don't know putting some uh
some links to papers that you you have
got inspired from
uh so it's great way to explain explain
your code also uh for example functions
and
classes you can specify types of your
arguments so
it's both for humans and for ideas
good good ideas
provide type type checking and when you
put the wrong type they
give you a warning
and for future you can build
automatically build some documentation
from your source code so it's very
convenient when you want to have
documentation for your project uh either
to keep it in house for only your
developers or to publish it somewhere if
you are writing open source tool so
people can read and understand what your
code does and how to use it
uh
this is a link for different styles for
python so uh
to organize the supply data after
this presentation i will give you uh the
slides so you can get the links for
mentioned in the presentation or you can
just contact me i will give it to you
uh so using the example of a dog string
in python uh is it visible
at the end
so
so it's just some some function that
destroys universe it it has two two
parameters first parameter is timer uh
it's type uh uh
i gave int
and by the way this style is called the
numpy style for documentation in python
yes
okay
it's more visible now
good thank you
and this multiverse dimension is string
so
my code my function expect to
get this type of
type of
arguments so when i gave a wrong
argument here it can happen
my id gives me an error that i gave
float instead of ink
so
in this case it may not be problem but
for example you have some big project
running on production and you forget
that your uh that your function gets a
numpy raise so it works on numpy arrays
but you uh on some somewhere on the code
you gave it uh
by torch fighter tray light or tensor uh
uh and it may break uh the function on
production and you will get errors and
you want to understand what's going on
and you must spend hours and hours on
debugging so
type checking
is powerful tool for
uh developers to understand uh
how that code that you or others brought
works
uh okay for uh dog string building uh
automatically building you can check out
mk docs it's a very uh easy tool to use
so it's very convenient to use on on
python
there are a lot of others like sphinx
but my favorite is mk docs
next
okay
as a date scientist all of us
work on jupiter notebooks or learn
learned their first
machine learning algorithms on jupiter
notebooks we
do a lot of a lot of experiments there
uh it's it's very convenient for us to
use but there
jupiter notebooks are evil so why is
that
because they don't give you enough
functionality to write a good code
so uh first for example they don't have
a good type checking they don't give you
warnings about uh types uh
they don't have good auto complete they
have but it's not very good like in uh
ids and the
these kinds of autocomplete uh
helps you to write code faster and
vmware engineers want to write code
faster because on that we use python
also
jupyter notebook is convenient that you
can use it cell by cell
but sometimes
that cell by cell usage it becomes the
evil part because
you can define your variable name in the
lower cells and use it in upper cells
and
when you restart your notebook your code
may break because
your variable is not defined and you may
need uh hours of debugging to understand
what's going on
uh also you can put
a long
long
lines of code there a very very long
module there
because it will be very messy and messy
to use
but we use jupiter notebooks we love
them i love love jupiter notebook too
but
you will need to use it
carefully and there's a rule of thumb
that you must
take your code from jupiter notebook
within 24 hours
you do
some experiment there you build some
model there and after that when your
code is ready you can take that code to
a proper id like uh proper id yet and
also uh also one
problem about the jupyter notebook that
you can't take them to production so
there's a data scientist asking when do
i get my notebook in production but the
envelopes
do not do that so
so you you just simply can't use all of
that functionality on youtube notebook
it's not convenient for that and it's
not a design for that so
use proper ids like in this slide for
example
uh good good examples or for uh ides
pycharm is my personal favorite uh i
love it really much and
it has a downside though it's uh good
features are on a paid version
but it's very the free version is also
very good tool
so it has anything you need as a data
scientist to work with your models
uh
on pro version it has uh so everything
here so debugging uh version control
terminal real time linking autocomplete
on pro version it has jupyter notebook
support which is bad on pycharm so don't
use it i every time just if i'm
writing code on python pro i use jupyter
notebook in another browser
it has database tools remote development
uh if you're doing a lot of uh trainings
you may need a remote server to do your
trainings there and also it has
scientific view uh for your plots your
date frames uh to view and see their
attributes it's very convenient uh
to use also it's refactoring its
debugger is very convenient also
reflecting too it's very convenient to
do in python to
move your classes and functions
within some modules
so next industry favorite is vs code
uh the one thing about one thing about
python pro uh
it's it's paid but you can get it with
your university emails if you're a
student if there are students here and
for educational purposes you can use it
next is vs code so industry also loves
it it's very convenient to use
personally i don't
like vs code much i'm more pie charm guy
but uh it's also very good tool
uh it it's free and has everything that
almost everything that pycharm does
also it has better debugger than in
pycharm so
yes
its debugger is better for example when
i uh
train something on a pycharm and i do
debugging there by charm debugger may
break just i don't know why it breaks
and nobody explains why but in vs code
it works really fine so the debugger is
good here
also it has in in up tensorboard
just
in the vs code so it's convenient to use
on the other hand uh here is the date
spell which is a id
developed by pycharm
developers jet jet brains
it's dedicated to to data scientists
especially especially
it's also a paid tool it has everything
gone by churn pro but it has more good
functionalities for us
it has better jupyter notebook support
both remote and local it's convenient to
use
except
how jupyter notebooks renders images i
don't know why but
it render renders in some weird colors
uh
it also has remote development if you're
also writing in r it has r console
building so you can use it too
scientific view very convenient uh also
it has one killer feature that i like
it's uh that you can divide dot pi file
to cell by cell running like in jupyter
notebook so i said that in jupiter
notebook that cell by cell running is
very dangerous to use uh
so for that reason you need to use dot
pi files for your code development
uh but still you sometimes need to run
your code cell by self for example uh
you're loading uh huge data and changing
everything uh on lower parts for example
some functionalities trying uh something
uh on your data
so uh in that case when you uh change
something uh you should
run dot pi file
all dot py file and you read that uh
huge data but in this case you you can
just divide those pi files cell by cell
and run run only the cells that you want
it's very convenient to use you can use
uh every functionality that
the date spell gives you for regular dot
pi files and you can use a jupyter
notebook advantage of running cells here
so it's convenient to use so it's a
one one or
one 1.5 years old of tool so it's still
actively developing
uh okay next uh
you can have you must have version
control for your project because
sometimes you may need to go back in
time to understand how your model worked
what uh
what bugs
bugs did you have so for backward sorry
for for backward compatibility you need
to have version control and for that you
must write good understandable commit
messages for yourself for your future
self when you write uh bug fix
next commit some commit some changes and
after six months you look to your code
you you want to understand what
what that change does you must just
enter the part of the code read the
changes and understand what you change
but
if you have good commit messages you can
read it and understand or your teammates
and commit as you as soon as you make
important change and don't commit to on
master because
always have if you're working in a team
always have someone to read your code
to
review your code and after that merge it
on master
next
as an mle engineer
data scientist
as a scientist especially you need to
make your experiment reproducible so
anyone after you can repeat your
experiment and get the same result so
for that you can fix it and randomness
but it's good to fix it
on some high level file that anyone can
read not from the
code definition
also it's good to fix versions of
packages that you are using
so for that have requirements txt or
setup.pi
so why is that packages tend to develop
and get updated so and after some time
uh for example if you are using uh deep
learning library by torch it may be
updated and your uh
code may may broke because of that
particular update uh and you you will
get some weird messages and you want to
understand what's going with your code
you spend uh hours of hours of debugging
and uh
after six hours you you understand that
it was just uh because of that package
change so happens to me
so
for that please fix fixed versions uh in
setup i you have more information so i
prefer having set up python requirements
here txt
and for your input files if your models
model have some input or your code
generally have inputs you can have one
input file for parameters from high
level so everyone can understand
on what part they need to do some change
to run another experiment not go deep on
the modules to change something
um about debugging we we have talked
about a lot of debugging so for sake of
debugging don't don't use print messages
use proper tools
and those
proper tools can include just python
logging module
it gives you a good good functionality
to log your code and
so logging your code is a proactive tip
because uh when you
log when you write your code after some
while when you run your code you you can
understand
how how things go well or
did something broken
on these steps or not
and you can uh
change the logging module a bit to your
preferences
and about model
you can also log your model results
intermediate steps some other metadata
like images tags uh whatever you are
working with
and
because it's very very convenient when
you do tons of experiments you need to
compare which one was good or bad
to pick the better one for that
you just simply can't remember
everything you need to have it stored in
some some location
preferably in one location if your team
also for your for your team uh you can
use it in one location so everyone can
get access to it and read it so
here are some cool tools that you can
use for ml experiment logging
first one is aimstack
about aim
their co-founder will have talk
during phi data so you can go and hear
them also
next one is neptune.ai
neptune is my favorite so far because
they also have good jupiter notebook
support
you can log jupyter notebooks there and
compare jupiter notebooks like you
compare
source files in github so you can't
compare jupiter notebooks in github for
example or gitlab
because it's some it puts
shows everything that jupiter notebooks
has it's the internal metadata but in
networking you can visualize
you can compare it visually
next tool is weights and biases and we
have mlfro here also so you can choose
your weapon and
log your
experiments so uh we are
we are data scientists and ml engineers
but for uh we write code and kodi
software so
for that have software design some
design uh for your project to be
understandable some apis that your team
will get and understand
you can follow some some designs for
software and also uh some concrete
examples that i want to mention uh use
modules and functions for
one purpose only it's known as single
responsibility principle when you have a
module responsible for
definitely everything it may become very
large for example few or three three
thousands of lines and uh
you may
get confused what
functions does what what classes are
doing and it's uh
very inconvenient to change something
there so when you're having uh
everything designed for one purpose only
you can you will know what part you need
to change so you you got that that
module you change that particular
function and you don't
change anything else next don't repeat
yourself so uh
this this principle can help you
by by this principle you must write some
classes and functions that
encapsulate some uh logic and
if you're having that logic in uh some
different parts of your code so your
code base won't be too too long so you
don't have some duplicates and it won't
be too long
and
for code you can follow some guidelines
in python we have pp8 or you can
define yours if you don't like ppit but
it's very good so guidelines are good
for code because
it
increases searchability uh in your code
uh it's it's very very convenient to you
and very understandable for example
in pp8 there is a guideline to use
not more than
76 i as i remember characters on one
line it's done so because when you
compare two source files on uh on id
together
so it becomes very convenient when you
have a very
long line so
these guidelines are for
these purposes
and avoid creating tech depth as much as
possible
techtech is that when you say i know
that this code is very bad i'm good
engineer i can write good code but we'll
go back to this later that later may
never come
so
for that avoid creating tech that this
may um
yeah and next you can read clean
architecture book for
more software design principles
he explains it very very good
with examples here's a
some picture showing what the tech depth
is
so you are firstly going very fast with
your senior engineer or whatever he is
and you may end up with
having some bugs and you can't go back
because you have created tech depth
along the line
and you need to work very hard here to
pull yourself out from this situation
uh
maybe it's final advice think iterative
so in in machine learning machine
learning especially
it's iterative science and engineering
because uh as i showed in in this
in this cycle you need to gather data
prepare data understand do eda build
some models analyze the data more train
it deploy it and you understand that
your model is not good enough you need
more data you need more you get more
business problems
uh so it becomes iterative progress
progress for that you may also
think iteratively to build good uh ml
project
so that's it thank you if you have any
questions
yes
thanks for the great talk a lot of
useful uh tips i have uh more uh uh
comment not a question regarding visual
studio code and maybe we'll give a
second chance to it because it actually
has a jupyter notebook support within it
and it means that you listed some
limitations of jupyter notebooks but
when you integrate jupyter notebook
inside vs code you get
automatically all the benefits like type
hintings linkings integrations with all
your other code base etc
and it also has a
execution of python script cell by cell
also in this code just two little things
yeah and thanks for the talk again yeah
thanks thanks for the advice yeah it's
very useful i will try on my next
project
for that for that purpose i i used date
spell on the date spell you can do that
uh same too but the fps code is free
thank you
there there's one question
uh thanks for uh your great uh
presentation
uh basically you uh you say that poor
design has some cost on the companies
and maybe in future work
uh
is there a kind of you know example poor
design you know good design do you have
a kind of uh tips for you know to
to maybe separate this
on my presentation i don't have uh code
examples of uh
high level for example
okay okay yes uh
that for particular particular example
that uh
when you when you write a very very long
very long module that does everything
for example it does a data manipulation
model building everything
in that single
module it's bad design for that
yes
it's one concrete example uh
there can be many many many examples
about that so
for example in python when you're
writing writing classes uh
the that different kind of different
classes may become entangled together so
it's also
a
bad design for your code so
about good design uh
i've mentioned about this poke clean
architecture and the robert c martin
he introduces and the
very long time ago introduced
solid principles so it's a solid uh
like first one is single responsibility
principle it's a
it's example of how good design should
be in general
following that principle thank you
excuse me
yes
because you can if you are giving for
example one example if you're giving
someone your code base for example a new
hire clones your code base from your
repository and uh he or she needs to
install everything uh
it can be done through requirements.txt
but the requirements takes team may
sometimes broke if you build it
automatically just writing a beep list
and everything uh but in
require in setup.5 you write it
every every package and their version
you write it by yourself
and
there's a cool a little uh
one liner that you can write and just
install your everything on your project
is the pip install setup.fire pip
install dot if you're on the same
location it will install everything
every dependency that you have and also
you can give some
more information in setup that by word
developers uh license about some
licenses in setup.pi and everything else
thank you
the last one the last one why didn't you
why didn't you mention python virtual
environment when you talk about
requirements txt uh yeah it's a good
question because i have time limitations
i can't talk about everything but it's
uh it's also good to have virtual
environment for everything you design
and every project you have
thank you for mentioning that
thank you